Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So Leute, ich bin gleich am Start.
Ich hab jetzt bloß schon mal Stream angemacht, dass Twitch das kapiert hat bis um 17 Uhr wenn es da los geht.
Jetzt kann ich mal raussuchen wo der Kram eigentlich läuft.
Wahrscheinlich Twitch, Xbox oder so. Geh ich mal vorne aus.
Und 3D? The fuck die gibt's noch? Was ist da los?
Warte mal, ja. Hier, wahrscheinlich hier geh ich mal vorne aus.
Boah, ja hier.
Ah, 13 Minuten.
Oh nice, man kann direkt jetzt...
Gut, das klingt glaub ich schon immer.
Wir werden aber normalerweise halt kein Chrome, da seh ich das nicht.
Okay, ähm, ja also, ich bin gleich am Start, ich muss noch was zu trinken holen.
Und das andere wollt ihr nicht wissen, ich muss mich hier noch anziehen, weil ich war grad duschen und ich hab gedacht ich muss jetzt Stehmann machen, bis das auch alles läuft, bis es los geht.
Mixer, Mixer, Alter.
Geh fort, Mixer.
Inside Xbox? Das ist ne Art Spiel, Alter.
Nein, Leute, das ist nicht Xbox.
Boah, warum ist der Champ so groß?
Champ Box.
Easy Box, easy Box, hört sich an wie was von Unity Media.
Das da, oh der passt gut, der passt gut.
Okay Leute, ich bin gleich da, was zu trinken holen, kurz ein paar Socken anziehen.
So, wieder am Start.
Ähm, wisst ihr was mir angefallen ist?
Ich hatte doch vor ein paar, aber warte mal, Kirby, Kirby muss mal kurz, Kirby muss mal kurz gemutet werden.
Wow, jetzt können wir schon mal die Lautstärke vom Xbox-Stream einstellen.
Ähm, mir ist eingefallen, ich hatte doch vor, vor einem Jahr oder so, als wir uns E3 angeguckt haben, hatte ich so nen Bullshit, so nen Bullshit-Counter oben rechts in der Ecke.
Und, ähm, wo ist denn der hin?
Ich hab das Programm dazu nicht mehr, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das gemacht hab mit dem Bullshit-Counter.
Leute, wir müssen in 9 Minuten einen neuen Bullshit-Counter programmieren, meint ihr, das kriegen wir hin?
Oder aber wir machen's mit OBS, nee, wir machen's mit OBS.
Äh, wartet mal, wie machen wir das am besten, wie machen wir das am besten?
Ähm, wie machen wir das am besten?
Wie krieg ich nen Bullshit-Counter jetzt am besten oben hin?
Äh, ich glaube OBS ist am besten.
Nee, nee, wir haben keinen Bullshit-Counter, eine Windows Forms alleine bringt mir ja nix, ich muss das Ding auch irgendwie fernsteuern können.
Kann OBS Textdateien einlesen?
Okay, Leute, wir probieren das jetzt mal ganz schnell, ähm, Alter, okay, mal gucken, okay, Bullshit-Counter schnell programmieren, okay.
OBS kann Textdateien einlesen, echt, echt, okay, Moment, äh, Text, nee, wo denn, wie geht das, weiß das jemand, Text, Text anlesen?
Browser, ich mach nen Browser und einfach auf HTML, was ich selbst aktualisiert, hä?
Moment, OBS Read Text File, geht das?
Text from File, add Text, add Text.
Create, okay, ähm, Bullshit-Counter, ah, Read from File, perfekt, perfekt, auch ein File hin hier irgendwie, mega null, da ist jetzt null drinnen, ah, sehr schön, sehr schön, sehr schön, ah, das gefällt mir.
Da müssen wir noch nicht selbst programmieren, da bin ich froh, dass wir das hier hinklatschen müssen, ähm, ah, funktioniert, okay, da müssen wir sagen auch Bullshit-Counter oder so hinschreiben.
Und dann nennen wir es, wie nennen wir es denn, ähm, Amazing-Counter, nee, super excited, PS-Counter, ähm, okay, da liest den Kram auch wieder ein, sehr schön, sehr schön, Schriftgröße, wir machen mal die Schriftgröße.
Vielleicht Fond, einfach der fetteste Fond, den es gibt, hier, und jetzt brauchen wir noch, übrigens danke für die Subs, ich hab's gesehen, vorhin war schon einer, der ist Spread the Beast, danke schön, Twitch Prime, Pog, alter.
Und jetzt haben wir hier noch mal den, ähm, den Twitch Mason, auch hier, Pog, nein, ich drücke das falsche, und dann hat man den Counter einrichten, okay, der Counter ist jetzt da oben in der Ecke, machen wir das jetzt am besten, ja.
PS-Counter ist zu lang, nennen wir jetzt einfach, Bingo, so, dann machen wir noch mal schnell eine andere Schrift, eine andere Schrift, irgendwas, so ein bisschen Outline oder sowas.
Kann das Ding denn Outline, Outline, Perfekt, Outline Color, noch mal Schwarz, dass es schön hervorsticht, genau, Outline Size, so ein bisschen größer, sehr schön, da kennt man jetzt ganz gut, denke ich, oder?
Wow, das hab ich jetzt gemacht, alter, cool, was war das, das Pog, alter, ja, dann klips mal, klips mal, klips mal und nenn's irgendwie Subscribersound oder so, dann kann ich's mir nachher noch mal anhören, der Milchmann, dankeschön, zwei Monate, okay, wir haben noch 5 Minuten Zeit, okay, dankeschön Milchmann.
Subscriber, okay, Bingo, jetzt muss ich mir nur noch überlegen, wenn ich jetzt OBS weg hab und ich pass die Textdatei an, das kann ich ja hier irgendwie hinmachen, so, aktualisiert das jetzt, einfach so, voll alleine, ah, sehr schön, Pog.
Also richtig, richtig nice wäre es jetzt natürlich, wenn ich das auf dem Netzlaufwerk hätte, dass ich den Kram aus dem Netz, vom anderen Rechner aus aktualisieren könnte, ne, da müsste ich nämlich gar nicht, da müsste ich nämlich gar nicht rumwursten.
Das waren wir jetzt, das waren wir jetzt, ah, Ordner, keine Ahnung, Share, da kommt's rein, passen wir das hier schnell an, wir haben ja immerhin noch 4 Minuten Zeit, Share, okay, ah, alter, das ist ja ne Kackfunktion, wenn man, oh jejeje, wenn man Steuerung S drückt.
Okay, Sharing, Share, ist mir doch vollkommen egal, wie Shared man das unter Windows, ich hab da keine, ich mach das zu selten, Choose, das Stream, Stream kann Shared.
Okay, Shared, oh ne, jetzt ist OBS wieder weg, jetzt ist OBS wieder da, ist der Kram jetzt Shared, ist der Kram jetzt Shared, okay, Windows, Windows gucken, das hab ich für ne IP, ich sag dir Leute, das wird Punkt landen, wenn das jetzt geht.
Ah, mein Backslash geht nicht, warum geht mein Backslash nicht auf dem anderen Rechner, achso, weil es mir der indische Tastatur eingestellt hat, äh, das stellt manchmal indische, indische Tastatur ein, ah, Windows Stream.
Desktop, Desktop, Desktop, so und jetzt Share und jetzt gucken, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob sich die Datei aktualisiert, wenn ich die update, noch mal eins reinschreiben, mal kurz warten.
Ha, funktioniert, nice, haben wir uns jetzt auf die Schnelle hingekriegt, easy, easy AF, okay Leute, also ich kann jetzt schon mal sagen, wir müssen uns auf ganz viel super excited, amazing stuff einstellen und achtet mal drauf, ich hab ja so nen Trend erkannt dieses Jahr, was die Pressekonferenzen angeht,
oh fuck, ich hab vergessen mein Chat, mein Chatclock zu starten, Professional Stream, Deluxe heute, achtet mal drauf, ich hab eine Sache bei den Präsentationen dieses Jahr ausgemacht, ich mach gleich Vollscreen,
ähm, und zwar, dass dieses, dass dieses Jahr weniger super excited und, also wird immer noch gelabert, also es wird immer noch Bullshit gelabert, aber, was dieses Jahr angesagt ist, und damit hat, hat Apple so ein bisschen den Trend gesetzt, was bei Pressekonferenzen was abgeht, dass die Leute, dass die Leute auf der Bühne mittlerweile die ganze Zeit sagen, yeah, oder, oder, oder woo, oder irgendwie sowas, achtet mal drauf, ich wette mit euch, das machen die hier auch so, okay, ich hab noch neun Sekunden Zeit,
schnell, Chatlock starten, come on, Ryder, starte, okay, dann starte nicht, alles klar, Vollscreen, geht los, wir müssen mal sagen, wie der Sound passt, ich mach mal ein bisschen lauter,
was, ah, Polar Dance,
was, neunte, dreizehnder, neunter, ich hab's nicht gesehen, Zielaufstärke, okay,
ja, vor allem Leute, die gerne drei Stunden in der Schlange stehen, die conversion da auch ziemlich,
ich guck einfach mal, wie der Sound gerade ist, ja, das passt so, das geht schon los, ich sag's euch, das ist der Trend dieses Jahr, dass man sich selbst anfeuert,
was, muss man die Leute eigentlich kennen,
wer ist das,
na, Bingo-Counter, ich weiß nicht, wie ich's nennen soll, Rage-Counter,
wie sie sich feiern, wie sie sich feiern die ganze Zeit,
wie sie sich feiern die ganze Zeit,